In terms of my question,
I think most of your belief that it's
extremely important and everything that
we're doing to speak our mind to speak
really that's why we're here,
but in terms of practicality,
there's a lot of things that get in the
way of our license students and we have
our gala with a perspective.
So,
um,
in terms of practicality,
what are kind of maybe your tips and
your perspective on the steps that
students can take to kind of speak their
mind while not sacrificing kind of
future prospects?
Well,
I can tell you a couple of things that
are very practical.
Don't break in your essays what you
think the professor wants to hear.
There's absolutely no excuse whatsoever
for doing that.
Now.
First of all,
most professors,
even those who have descended into an
estate of ideological possession,
let's say most of them still have enough
character to grade an essay that's well
written properly.
So you're actually taking less of a risk
than you would think by stating what you
have to take.
But look,
if you start practicing when you're in
university,
when mistakes are rather low,
pandering to the audience,
let's say and say what you think will
get you by,
you're going to train yourself to do
that,
and once that means is you're going to
train yourself in the false suffocation
of your character and your character is
the only thing you have to guide you
through life.
No people dream of riches and they dream
of luxury and all of that.
But that's a thin defense against the
harsh realities of the world.
You have your character,
and so what you do when you go to
university is you learn to say what you
think is clearly as you can and to take
the slings and arrows that come along
with that.
Not In an arrogant manner,
right?
Because like,
what the hell do you know?
You know,
so you've got plenty to learn,
but you want to formulate your thoughts
carefully.
You want to write what you think.
Well,
why?
Because when you're writing,
you're thinking,
you're laying out the arguments that
you're going to use to structure your
existence in the world throughout your
entire life,
and if you start to twist and bend those
for expedient reasons,
you're going to warp your soul,
and I mean I could talk about that
neurophysiologically if you want to.
You know,
you become what you practice.
You automate what you practice,
so if you automate expedient speech for
the sake of short term gain,
then that's what you're going to
produce.
You're going to produce expedient speech
for short term gain.
Well,
God help you if you do that,
like there is nothing that you will
possibly do in your entire life that
will serve you better than to get
control of your voice in university I've
ever see you do that by reading,
right?
You read great people.
You do that by writing what you think.
You stay true to yourself while you
write what you think and you take the
risks and you gain the benefits that go
along with that.
You learn to stand up and speak and to
listen carefully and that makes you a
negotiator of unparalleled power,
and if you're a negotiator of
unparalleled power,
there's nothing the world that won't
open itself up to you,
so that's what you're doing in
university and if you find professors
who who reject that and there's fewer of
them than you might think,
then it's your sacred obligation to
stand up for yourself against that
because it's going to happen to you
throughout your whole life and you might
as well start practicing how to do it
right now.
So that's how it looks to me.
Yeah,
there's an old saying that I,
I right.
Thank you.
I write in order to know what I think
and you'll note how compelled speech
interferes in that process.
Yes.
So the idea that you have to write what
your professor wants is a form of
compelled speech.
It's like,
I really do believe that this is a
fundamental issue.
As a therapist say when I'm trying to
help someone set their life straight,
I do my best not to compel their speech.
And the reason for that is quite clear.
It's like you have your destiny with all
its attended,
triumphs and sufferings and it's on your
shoulders.
I don't want to tell you how to think.
I don't want to tell you how to think
because I do not know how you should
think.
You have to figure that out for yourself
and then you have to bear the
responsibility for that and you are a
terribly arrogant fool if you dare to
tell someone else how it is that they
should conduct themselves through life.
Now,
having said that,
while obviously I say,
well,
you should tell the truth,
or at least you shouldn't lie,
but that's not a dictate of,
of,
of action,
so to speak.
It's a dictative process.
It's like,
well,
you can't.
You shouldn't interfere with the
mechanism that allows you to solve all
the problems that you will face in your
life and you come to university maybe to
prepare for a trip for a,
for a profession,
no,
and to set yourself up economically,
but to set yourself economic
economically,
properly.
I don't care what your profession is
going to be.
There is no one who is more powerful
than someone who can communicate.
It doesn't matter what the field.
It doesn't matter if you're a plumber or
a politician.
If you can formulate your thoughts
clearly.
If you can conduct yourself honorably in
your action and your speech,
if you're articulate and careful,
then the world opens itself up to you.
You have an unlimited horizon of
possibility,
so thank you very much.
Thank you.